right off the bat let's dispense with
the whole objectivity thing no one's
always right objectively but you can use
tricks and sofas tree when logic and
facts on your side to always be right in
an argument the whole goal here is to
try to win it's an intellectual war ergo
all's fair in love and arguments I think
Sun Tzu said that once this is gonna be
an abridged list of dirty little tricks
taken from archers Schopenhauer's book
the art of being right the full book and
audiobook is linked below I've just
picked my favorites let's get into it
first postulate what has to be proved
this is where you bring up a conclusion
as if it were a premise it's also known
as begging the question here's an
example I began this campaign because I
was so tired of seeing such foolish
things happen to our country notice how
he says the reason I began this campaign
is because the country was doing so
poorly he never proves how the country
is doing poorly or why it's doing poorly
he states it as a matter of fact up
front postulate what has to be proved
this is a great way to sneak your point
past the goal posts next choose your
definitions this works best at the start
of an argument if you want to control
the conversation try to control the
definitions what someone might call
extremism another person might call
passion what some call a right to
assembly others might call disrespectful
or disruptive here's an example from a
recent debate pay attention to how much
time is spent framing the other person's
position and conversely how much the
other one fights against this framing
they both know that the words you use to
define the other person's position is
everything he ran as a socialist an
unalloyed socialist all ran as an
independent observing independent the
history of the United States power are
you a socialist or not I am a Democratic
Socialist a bloke's
but don't Tom I didn't run as a
socialist I ran you told me you were
socialist fine fine you did run as a
right-winger you ran as a Republican
right I am happily episode
I am frame the conversation your way no
matter if you're talking about gender or
unemployment how you define it is
everything number three persuade the
audience not the opponent if you're in
front of an audience
tactically it doesn't matter if the
person to your left or right agrees with
you only the crowd this is pretty easy
it's the quip the one-liner whatever
gets the laugh the most important thing
to remember here is the audience isn't
just there to see who objectively wins
it's a spectacle they want to laugh they
want to see who looks more composed
under the lights I have as much spirits
in the Congress as Jack Kennedy did when
he sought the presidency senator I
served with Jack Kennedy
I knew Jack Kennedy senator you're no
Jack Kennedy
[Applause]
if you notice the opponent seems to
wither after this mind but he really
didn't say much at all number four the
Kafka trap this is a particularly rude
trick frame and accusation such that the
denial is only further evidence of guilt
think the Red Scare or witch hunts when
you accuse someone of something and they
refuse it just say oh that's what
someone like that would say here's an
example from Monty Python if you deny it
you did it
that's a Kafka trip five arguments ad
hominem if all else fails you personal
attacks are always a great diversion to
get off a particular point you're losing
the examples here are endless I think we
can have a rational political
conversation about balancing rights and
risks and rewards of all of these
different policies but I don't think
that what we need to do is demonize
people on the other side is as being
unfeeling about that about what happened
in yesterday you accuse me of spending
on the grades the children that die that
day I've seen you do it repeatedly curse
like I say how dare you hire people
illegally and entered a 1 million dollar
judgment I got along with everybody you
get along with nobody you don't have one
Republican you don't have one Republican
senator and you work with them every day
of your life although you skipped a lot
of time these are minor details but you
don't have one Republican senator
backing you not one you don't have the
endorsement of one Republican senator
and you work with these senator Cruz you
should be ashamed of yourself notice how
in both cases ad hominem was used to
distract to deflect the underpinning
question this technique is very
effective and finally we come to number
six the absurd proposition this is where
you offer an extreme scenario where you
equate things that aren't equal at all
but if you disguise it well enough and
if your opponent can't find where your
arguments falling apart it can pressure
them into agreeing with your point
here's another example a la South Park
are you guys dub we can't beat him even
with all of us it's a waste of time
if you had a chance right now to go back
in time and stop Hitler wouldn't you do
it I'm just gonna stop plague when
Hitler rose to power there are a lot of
people who just stop playing you know
who those people were
the French are you French glad no rouler
vous coucher avec ma glad alright
alright I'll do it if your opponent
doesn't spot the trick this is a
particularly effective tactic that's
everything I'm gonna give you scandals
right now the full list is in Archer
Schopenhauer's book the secret is to
disguise these within an argument so
that people don't know that you're
playing tricks but if you can do this
well you'll find yourself being right
more often than you thought possible but
even if you're trying to be fair and
honest in an argument knowing these is
always helpful to keep the other guy
honest knowing how people want to fight
dirty is the best defense to fight clean
but either way whether you're running
for office or in a late-night argument
please fallacy responsibly
[Music]
[Applause]